Alex thank you so much for agreeing to
talk to me I've wanted to talk to you
ever since this war in Ukraine started
and particularly so since you came and
joined my club Arsenal which I've
supported all my life
because to watch a player like you
having to go on a football pitch
twice a week
with all this going on back in your home
country
so me you must have incredible mental
strength how difficult has it been for
you
well um thanks a lot for this invitation
it's a it's a really pleasure to talk to
you and um I tell you honestly I I'll be
honest I'll try to be honest
um
it was not easy you know to adapt on
this
but unfortunately unfortunately
all of us I'm talking about football
players and
which is playing abroad uh it's not easy
you know to be to be far away from the
home and then watching all these scary
things which is happening but
um
I remember quite well
first couple of weeks that I just lost
my hat I I didn't know where I am I
didn't know where I'm driving to to to
to the training ground where I didn't
know honestly I was like in this space I
couldn't believe that that this has
happened
and uh but in the end you know
there is two options you just
keep being in the space
or you have to do your best to help to
help your country to help Ukrainian
people
um as much as you can you have to
represent your country in the best way
you could so
that that this is the conversation was
between all of us broad players which is
playing for the national team and uh
obviously that was my or my decision to
to carry on to to to do my best and to
help as much as I can because I know
that I'm well will be much much more
helpful to my country and to the people
from here rather than being there but I
really want to be there when did you
know that Russia had invaded your
country well it was a deep night
I was sleeping because I had session in
the morning and my wife suddenly woke me
up and she said
it started I said what started she was
crying you know like full in tears and
what started what's wrong and she just
showed me the the videos the pictures
uh of this invasion so that's how it all
started and that's how I obviously you
know if you look at a bit back
um
the the the
look let me let me let me be clear some
some of the people still think or they
still talk that this is a conflict
between two countries but this is not
conflict this is a proper War right and
this war started in 2014.
when I was like 17 or something right
and I didn't I couldn't even understand
what was what's going wrong and
they took Crimea and donbass without any
resistance and you were playing at
shaktar donation yeah time and you
couldn't play right
well uh all shakhtar moved to the other
city but I had another story Football
story which we can speak later a bit but
I'm talking about just the general
Invasion and they took Crimea and
donbass without any resistance in 2014
and no one no one could understand
what's obviously happened
um
and then obviously in 2022
um since the the main Invasion across
the whole Ukraine
scary to be honest it's scary I still
cannot understand For What to achieve
what I mean it was terrifying to watch
it and I'm not Ukrainian I can't even
imagine what it must have been like for
you and your family to watch your
country being illegally invaded and in
such a brutal barbaric manner where very
quickly Russian forces were committing
atrocities war crimes you know I went to
Buca when I went to to Ukraine and heard
some of the stories there of the
appalling Massacre there to actually be
Ukrainian and watch these scenes must
have been an appalling thing
imagine the place where you was born and
raised you know every single Stone there
you know everything around yourself
you know the people around yourself you
have some some friends I don't know job
and then one day
someone from the other countries with
the guns coming there destroying
everything around raping
your I don't know your woman kids
killing men
and then
living
stealing everything around everything
would you achieve what you I don't know
what you bought before
no reason
you reckoned in 2022 this is possible
I don't I don't know
but it is
and you know using this kind of
opportunities even to talk to you
I would like to to send another message
to the rest of the world I know some
people got fatigue
I know this
but why it's so important to keep going
to keep pushing to to stick to be to be
together to stick together and to win
this
terrorist invasion
it's so important because today Ukraine
is a shield for all the Europe
and you never know today is Ukraine but
tomorrow it could be I completely agree
it could be your country it could be any
country exactly and also this is for the
future
like if one guy is gonna sit in his
office and gonna think well
I have enough power to take this land
this land this land he must to know
from the experience in the past all the
world is going to stick together and
it's impossible
so that's what we have to do what are
you my opinion what are your thoughts
about Vladimir Putin
I don't want to even say his name I
don't want to even say his name or to
talk about him it's incredible honestly
just yesterday I watched um because I'm
following all the news and I watched
a short clip of his video when he was
talking to someone sitting on the table
I don't know even these people who was
there around it's like young men in in
girls
and he was talking about
which they destroyed
one week ago
and he was saying that
obviously Ukraine did it
well
hundred thousand of people lost their
houses
some of them didn't survive
there there was one Zoo 300 animals
died
and everyone was talking about Ukrainian
uh Ukrainian counter attack I'm talking
about Army
and then he was saying in the video he
was saying Ukraine did it because
they were planning to do counter-attack
and then this dumb
make them so slow slower
and like you're just trying to put it in
your head well you are a Ukrainian Army
you want to do counter attack
and you destroying dumb
to make your contract slower
makes no sense
and he's just saying this I was like
watching no no I need to watch it again
maybe I didn't hear properly so he's
lying to to himself he did yeah I don't
know
I I know that there is a proper
propaganda I know because I had
experience to playing there but I never
followed the news or whatever
but honestly
like if I had some circle when I was
playing there now this circle became to
zero because I don't understand people I
was going to ask you you went and played
in the Russian Premier League for one
and a half season yeah
um and you did that because of what was
happening in the Dom bass and your
family moved to Russia and your Russian
speaking of course
you must have made lots of friends
in Russia or any of these people still
friends with yours or have you had to
not a lot to be honest not a lot
um well
I know that I had this experience in my
life right
um but and some of the people from
Ukraine they don't they don't like it
obviously and to be honest at the moment
me too right but but
um I'm human being and I understand one
thing that I would like to say again
thanks to FC
UFA
for everything what they have done the
Russian team yeah where I played yeah
but that's it
that's obviously that's it I I would
like to say that thanks to the to them
that they took that risk because I had a
tough situation between me and shaktar
Donetsk and they took that risk they
signed me without any views
so I never played on the professional
level and they took me
um and then obviously with that
opportunity I signed this contract with
City but that's it that's the only thing
to fcufa for for everything what they
have done to me the rest obviously the
reaction afterwards since Invasion not
from the clubs any Russian clubs not
from the football players I never seen
that and I would never understand
I had the chat with one of the not one
of the I would say the the famous one at
the moment in Russia Sportsman not from
football I'm not gonna say his name but
he is very famous I had chat with him
alike because I unfollowed him in
Instagram and he asked me why did you do
that I said listen there's it's already
since months six three months since
invasion and you didn't even say
anything you have millions of followers
you didn't post even one picture to stop
these scary things
I would never understand this because if
if this one would happen with Ukraine
and Ukraine invade anyone else
I swear to God I will be the first one
who's gonna scream like to stop it and I
would never come back are they scared
for their lives I don't know did he just
saw the message you can see that he saw
the mess but he didn't reply I mean I
guess a lot of them would say that they
feel in fear of their lives because
Putin has killed people who stood up
against him in this war well I tell you
I'll give you another example there was
one player X player he used to play for
locomotive Dynamo Moscow he used to be a
captain for the Russian national team
Igor Denise of his name
um he gave one interview
the way he was soaking
like how bravely it was
um about you just said listen if I would
be a still player current player after
24 of February I would retire really
well the way he was talking and what's
happened with him I never I didn't even
hear anything to him he is in prison or
this is example this is a poor example
the guy with the big boss
talking in front of the people in front
of 140 or how many millions they have
incredible stuff and this is the normal
reaction from normal people
but unfortunately there is not many of
them we've seen some Ukrainian athletes
Sports people now refusing to shake
hands with other Russian or Belarusian
athletes how do you feel about that if
you had to come up against a team and
had a Russian player would you shake
that no chance no chance because I would
never accept their reaction
honestly I have to be honest
um do you think it's cowardly the the
lack of reaction
I'm totally agree with with this
reaction
it's not even it's impossible it's not
there's no point to even explain it
um
the the things look you can say well but
they didn't do anything against us or
something yes they did they did how and
what they didn't react
look they have followers behind them
millions followers in social media or
wherever they have a lot of chances to
to speak out to the people which is
following them
and if you have let's say 10 million
followers in Instagram and you post some
people I don't know one picture like
stop it just you know black form stop it
some people from this 10 million is
going to follow you they're gonna spray
this as well to someone else
and it will work in the end but if no
one is going to speak out because they
scare I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry don't don't ever call us
brothers or whatever like they did it in
the past never again
that's my that's my uh Wimbledon Tennis
for example has just said they will
allow Russian and Belarusian players to
play this year having banned them before
do you agree with that decision no
chance even though she doesn't know I
don't agree I don't agree on that I'm
one of the I have one of the ukrainians
which is uh which is
which don't like to see them in in any
on the highest level in any sport so
they should just be exactly and do you
think both countries Russia and Belarus
for sure 100 they shouldn't be allowed
to compete shouldn't be allowed why
because how many bombs and Rockets been
sending from Belarus
how many listen I'm not listen I'm not
political I didn't understand anything
about it I don't understand and I would
never understand it because this is not
my area
but
this is not political you that's life
and death This Is War and they're
talking about don't put politic in sport
this is not politic This Is War guys you
don't do anything
to be
I'm not saying on our side on the
Justice side yeah
do you know people who've lost their
lives
of course I know people friends of yours
well not like close close friends but
yes friends the people you knew people I
knew they've been killed yeah killed
destroyed by bombs in their homes yeah
if they didn't do anything like bad to
them but and they didn't deserve it do
you spend your entire time just checking
to see what's happening every single day
I don't know how many hours honestly
just what just just washing in the
morning first what I'm what I do I'm
taking my phone and checking all the
news
how does it make you feel
like I said unfortunately unfortunately
we already get used to it to this
routine and we have to be we have to be
strong you have family of course in
Ukraine yeah I mean you must worry
yourself sick about them
well of course I'm so worried about them
and I'll tell you what um
the mentality of people they don't want
to live
they don't want to leave the country
even if they could
um
this is their Homeland
and I would like for sure after football
career I will be living in Ukraine
that's for sure one million because I
didn't have been there for two years and
now I was a trip there
one week ago and obviously as soon as I
passed the Border
it's just my homeland
this is my place I can't imagine what
it's like for example to have your
parents
living in a country at War when you're
here how is that for you sort of
psychologically to have to deal with
that
well it's not easy
um
it's not easy to
it was not easy from the beginning
but you know when you already in this
routine you just you're just getting
used to it and uh
the thing is if you follow all the
instructions
in terms of siren and you hide yourself
in the bunker you more or less say but
you never know because
even last night they destroyed they
destroyed
I don't know one building in Odessa
three people die straight
so I don't know you went back to Ukraine
very the first time you've been there
since the war started
it's one thing to see video footage on
the news or on social media it's another
to be there to see the actual
Devastation when I went to Kiev last
summer to be to be able to go to places
like Buca and see what had happened and
to talk to people who've been caught up
in that who'd lost loved ones who'd been
shelled he'd had people they knew raped
and murdered I mean it was horrific what
was it like for you as a Ukrainian to go
back to your country and actually see it
well it's completely different when you
see it from the from your phone or
rather than from your eyes
um
painful you know
it's not like scary oh because I've seen
it every I've seen it by by social
medias and stuff but it's so painful
it's so painful how people
um
suffering how people trying to survive
and
I don't know it's just it's just a
simple example um
it's
thanks to our president that he
made this made this happen I mean I'm
talking about Ukrainian football and
season is still there obviously without
funds but as soon as the siren is there
you have to stop to playing football you
have to hide yourself in the bunker and
then wait until siren is done and
instead of 90 minutes of the game the
game could be three hours
and this is the reality you know
I was talking to the Lots here and to
the staff and one of the Kidman here
said to me like I used to say to my kids
almost every single day that how lucky
they are like look at the people there
it's it's so hard you know to carry on
there and uh
to do your best to try to achieve
something in this kind of facilities uh
but well we don't have another option we
just have to keep going we have to we
have to be stronger
um obviously I've been in the school
which they destroyed by the way it's
around 800 schools been destroyed by Uh
Russian bombs
uh 220 of them is impossible to rebuild
anymore
you just have to build a new a new one
and the rest you can rebuild but
obviously all of them is kind of
different kind of damage and one of them
we're gonna rebuild using this charity
game which is coming in August and I've
seen all these damages and um I was
talking to the kids
which is study there
and listening the story from stories
from them then they how kids can lie to
you it's impossible they don't even know
what lies what were they telling you
like they were saying to me that Russian
army
is coming to their houses you know
stealing some stuff doing scary things
which I'm not gonna say here
scary you know like the proper mental
injury for all of them for all their
lives this is the most scary thing I
guess you played with Andre shevchenka
you played a bit of football with some
of these kids just knock around
and that was a wonderful little moment I
guess of escapism for them
and then of course you come back here
and they carry on they're living in this
life day in day out are you worried
about the general impact on the mental
health of all these Ukrainian kids well
even after after war will be a lot of
drop to do especially like mental job
because this is a
this is a proper injury
proper injury which they're gonna
carry with them all their lives and um
I don't know obviously how to solve all
this all these problems but for sure
there will be we will find a way because
even watching the office president you
know where I've been
the way people work the energy the
passion the it's incredible incredible I
went there I interviewed president
zielinski last year and I thought hey he
was incredibly impressive but you're
right everyone around them they're
working all day every day seven days a
week month after month and Incredibly
difficult circumstances but I do feel
zelenski is like Winston Churchill was
for us in World War II he's become this
figurehead of resistance
that's for sure that's for sure um
that's why I'm saying that with this
kind of people and with this President
we have a bright future and we want to
find a way how to sort everything out
and using that opportunity to talk to
him personally I just said because
listen I had a bit like scenario on what
I had to say
um not a scenario I'm talking about I
knew what I have to say I know that
we don't have to waste his time and we
have to be like straight straight in and
the idea was to explain him the charity
match which is coming to help to rebuild
one of the school in certainly have
region
and but before that I using that
opportunity I said from myself and from
my all my family that how proud We Are
that you are our president and
everything what you are doing
is incredible so we are so proud all of
us I mean me and my circle and that's
true that's actually true he became our
our
leader like
you can imagine since the invasion well
that moment on the first night yeah yeah
that's what I was trying when he did
that video in his combats with guys
around him and he said I'm not going
anywhere that was powerful for me that
was the moment where the country looked
to their leader and he was going to stay
even if it many died and uh this is
about this story as well when um
U.S president calling you and saying
that look I know I have information that
you target number one and your family
Target number two
please let me take you somewhere they
they will never find you
and he said listen
I really appreciate everything what you
are doing and stuff
but I don't need taxi I need guns and
bullets how you're not going to follow
this this president
how you're not gonna how are you not
gonna I don't understand what's
incredible about him is that he was
before all this he was you know five
years ago he was a TV star
it's crazy to think that this guy who
was just known on Ukrainian television
for sort of light entertainment has
become such an influential and inspiring
wartime leader isn't it
well
um yeah it's incredible stuff but uh in
the same time
I used to say
it doesn't matter what you'd have done
in the past
it's so important who you are today
and what are you doing today
so the job he's doing is honestly I have
no words about this seeing that from
inside
even don't understand a lot of things
still
um
but people say he should do a deal he
should end the war bring the peace
by giving Russia
some of the land they've taken what do
you feel about that no chance listen how
many imagine imagine you lost someone
from your circle
and uh
no no let's go let's go to the beginning
I was born and raised
knowing that Crimea is and donbass is
Ukraine yeah I spent five years of my
life the most of the beautiful five
years in my life in Donetsk amazing City
amazing
and then at some point
it's already Russian how
for what
do they have do they have the do they
have rights to do that
why we should give them how many people
already been killed
how many buildings was destroyed
and why we should give them I don't
understand so you reckon you lost
someone from your circle and then in one
day
um
we're gonna do that like you said we're
gonna give them land and then you're
gonna sit and well
I lost one of my circle
for the reason because we were fighting
for that
and now you you gave them like this just
your reaction
your feelings do you feel most
ukrainians feel this way they shouldn't
give an inch for sure 100 I don't know
why they still
um
try sending every single night bombs to
Ukraine during the night from 1am until
five you know where you when you sleep
so so deep
obviously why like in my opinion maybe I
can be wrong like to keep people in fear
yes to to let to try to push people to
go against our president let us go
against our president to break them at
all right yeah exactly so that's what
they're trying to reach
and people living with that already more
than one and a half year do you believe
Ukraine can win the war
I don't believe I know
I know we're gonna win we already won
because they didn't expect what we're
gonna do they didn't expect this maybe
they thought like they're saying uh for
three days they do parrot parrots in
Kiev City Center or what they were
thinking I don't know
it's impossible to give our uh our
homeland like like this our place where
we're born and raised and to people who
say like you say they've got they've got
tired by it all they got bored if you
like
what do you say about what Ukraine needs
now in terms of Firepower would you like
to see countries like the UK who've been
very good so far but also the United
States and other countries do you want
to see them give Ukraine more Weaponry
give them more ability to win the war I
would love to see this but in the same
time what they what they know and what
they what they can see that they're
giving
everything what they can but of course
obviously you never know all of us we
will never know is it everything or is
not everything but still I would like to
say using this opportunity I would like
to say massive thanks for all the help
around the world and support which we
received and receiving every single day
and uh I really appreciate that I mean
many United Kingdom people have taken in
Ukrainian families are you grateful that
they've done that well I'm so proud of
this moment honestly since the invasion
started the little kids used to come to
me in the shop I was thinking like maybe
they want to make picture or something
no they they came to me like saying uh
Alex we are praying for all your people
in your country and we hope it will
finish very soon so it means a lot for
me you know it means people staying with
us
how how does it being
to play football at an elite level also
we're chasing the Premier League title
this season very nearly won it how hard
has it been for you
to try and perform to the level that
you're used to performing at with all
this going on
look football is my life this is the
place
where I feel most comfortable myself
and this is the place
when I'm on the pitch
I just forget everything around myself
I'm just in the game
enjoying these moments and uh
it's everything from your head how you
how you behave how you react on this
this sometimes I'm losing my head from
the morning straight away seeing the
news
all day don't touch me please just make
easy make you emotional so much so much
but now I guess I have no emotions at
all inside I'm completely empty because
I'm a sensitive person to be honest
um
and seeing all these scary things I I
think I left I left it all
and um
uh you said it's hard and not hard
it's hard for the people which is
staying on the Forefront line taking the
risk of their lives every single second
having a babies at home families wives
it's hard you told a story I think about
a woman who had two young children
babies
and when the dam was blown up
she died
and you had some knowledge of this woman
I think
well I read it in the social media and
then I asked a couple of people a couple
of volunteers is it true or not and they
said yes unfortunately it's true it's
hard to read it was so hard to read and
I couldn't even believe I really didn't
want to believe in that
and I was just thinking about this for
two days and then I was calling some
some of the people which is helping
there in that region and
they said unfortunately it's true
honestly it's it's it's it's hard it's
just that image when I read that of this
woman with these two babies
and then the water was coming and she
knew she was probably gonna die with her
kids it's just it's not just
heartbreaking it's enraging isn't it
and the question is to achieve what
they donate for to achieve what
you know that in that region there is a
lot of plants
growing before it used to grow and now
when all water will go down it's not
going to grow anymore
for years it's a big ecological
catastrophe massive
how you can describe them you've got
this massive game on August the 5th
you're going to play for arsene Wenger
obviously the Arsenal managerial Legend
and in fact he nearly signed you a few
years ago so you finally get to play for
him well do you know this story no tell
me well um
I was 17 years old and I played 16 or 17
doesn't matter uh we play Champion use
Champions League against Arsenal away I
don't know how it was but the rules was
um we went out we went through the group
stage
um
we became second
and the player playoffs was playing from
one game not home and away and because
you became second you had to play away
game and we played against Arsenal actor
bellerin team Serge nabri
um
these kind of players
tough game
one one half time
we did well then in the beginning of the
second half we had incredible chance 1v1
we didn't score and then they scored two
quick goals and the game was over 3-1
and after a few weeks after that game
one of the agents called me and said
like Alex arson benger was on that game
and he really wants you to take in the
first team straight
I was like well I'm playing for shakhtar
Donetsk under 19 not even under 21 and
he wants to take me in the first team of
Arsenal
it's probably a joke
he said no no it's true he's true he
said well if it's true just make it
happen please
and then obviously I don't know what's
actually happened
in the end but
the rumors went down back to zero
and when I had chance and opportunity to
ask him personally if it's true or not
because he came to one of the game at
Emirates the last season
and he said as soon as I started to
speak mister I want to ask you one
question
is it true or not that when shark
tardones used to play in use Champions
League against Arsenal as soon as he
just stopped me and said he's told me
then Stadium he told me the stadium
where we were playing I didn't even know
the name he said yes that Stadium I was
there after half time I called I said
so I was like wow imagine imagine I had
this I had this opportunity to be there
did you explain why he didn't sign you
well I didn't even ask this because I
know that you know all this process to
to to to make a transfer is a big big
job so agents there's a kind of irony
isn't there that you play for a team
called Arsenal that's named after
ammunitions
Factory
a Munitions Factory
the Gunners Arsenal that the name comes
from Munitions so there's an irony there
that you're now a Ukrainian well yeah of
course you're playing for Arsenal right
which is a symbolism of defense and
Destiny fighting back
destiny
I don't know I had a obviously I I
nobody could expect what's going to
happen
but I always had a dream to play for
this team and not because of the amazing
name of the club but just because I
really love to watch the way how they
played we're going to win the league
next year Alex
I hope so we're gonna do I've been very
upset for a few weeks now well not only
you trust me and all the team will
really feel it and
um you know the energy from the funds
from all around the world not just
Emirates or away stadiums it was
incredible I never felt this in my life
and uh
trust me
if not if everyone everyone around the
world is so disappointed and angry trust
me all the players and stuff five times
more
honestly five times more
but like uh we spoke about this about
this before uh these cars will make us
much much stronger that's for sure
we will take the the best from this and
this is amazing experience for us we
have a such a young team but with a lot
of experience already and
[Music]
um
we will try our best in the next season
too yeah Bill shankly the great
Liverpool manager said football is not a
matter of life and death it's more
important than that
but for you of course
nobody needs to tell you what's most
important it is literally life and death
back home for you
as I given you a proper perspective not
that you may have needed it but about
football than in the end okay
we didn't win the Premier League but
nobody died right where you come from
right now every day people are getting
killed
well all of us ukrainians we we are
praying and we're hoping that um
our Victory is not far away and all of
us you know I'm talking about the rest
of the world's all the people which is
helping us and supporting us we believe
that we're gonna we're gonna beat this
Invasion that's for sure you're going to
be a father again soon and you have a
little two-year-old girl
as having your own child and another
child to come has that given you
something extra when it comes to how you
think about this war and what's going on
with the young kids about care
I'll be honest with you
when I'm playing or
seeing my daughter smile I'm over the
moon I'm straight away forgetting about
everything around myself and in the same
time
I'm just thinking about being a DOT I'm
just thinking about about the people in
there which have exactly the same kids
and then some of them
been killed for no reason
some of them didn't come back home
and
I don't know makes me so disappointed
so disappointed have you wanted to join
the fighting yourself if there will be a
time
everyone will be there
it will be the last call or something or
wherever it will be a call we go all of
us we go here we go everyone will go you
would fight for Ukraine of course of
course but in the same time I'm just
thinking about today uh I'm thinking
about that
I'm much much more helpful from here at
the moment but
listen you never know what's going to
happen maybe if maybe this is the last
speech when we're going to speak to each
other you never know you never know
and um
how many people already been killed
by this invasion
I'm not seeing myself hiding somewhere
Alex it's been an honor to talk to you
honestly thank you for your time thank
you I wish you all the best of this game
it's going to be star-studded lots of
great players can we have a few names
Gerald pique I think is playing and uh
Clarence C Dorff you've got some other
friends of yours you've wrote in Robert
pereza here yeah well you said already a
lot of names and
um
to be honest uh we would like to
announce it step by step are you looking
for a slightly older Striker
are you ready are you feeling off
you don't wake up with a body like this
without a lot of hard work and effort
yeah Alex I'm ready for the cool okay
let's speak with our manager let's speak
with our manager
I'm not quite as fast as I used to be
but I'm lethal in the 60s you're like me
yeah okay slow slow on this with the
fish
um well you said already a lot of names
but for sure there will be a lot of
Legends on the beach
and a lot of people which is which will
be able to watch it from the stadium or
even buy TV they're gonna have fun but
the main target is from this match is to
raise the funds for the for the for the
school engineer region to rebuild it and
um
obviously apart from this this is
another powerful message to the rest of
the world that
obviously we stick together we stay
together
um
and all these people from different
International nationality I mean
different different countries they stay
with us look the the leaders from
different countries Brazil or wherever
they stay with us
so even this is another message to the
Russian civilians which is still
believing and supporting what they do
this is another message like okay you
can watch your propaganda for 20 years
on the same same TV channel and you can
believe in this but in the same time in
the end of the day you can just think
well
okay this is one information but from
the other side all the world is against
us
maybe they have a reason or maybe this
is maybe I need to find the the real
truth so you never know obviously I lost
my hope
already like a long time ago
I'm talking about Russian civilians that
they can do anything I lost my hope I'm
not hoping anymore but still you never
know
when I interviewed your President we
ended it with the words Slava Ukrainian
yeah I wish you all the very best for
you and your family thank you so much
and to your country thank you so much I
think you're going to win
and I think that's going to be a
powerful message that dictators can't
just invade countries when they feel
like it and kill everyone they feel like
I know we've been a village and do what
they want actually they can be held
accountable I know we're going to win
for sure
Alex thank you very much thank you good
to see you thank you